[Music]
you have a really nice place is this one
of those 1920s railroad apartments yeah
yeah thanks sorry about the mess
I wasn't expecting any visitors oh it's
fine I see you're an art collector that
is art right yeah yeah it is a hundred
percent paper mache it kind of reminds
me of childhood so everything seems so
much bigger back then you know but as an
adult you know things just seem to get
less big yeah well it's also a dick oh
yeah that is oh there there's a vein
which it's very tastefully done well
enough about my art collection what kind
of things are you into oh I'm into a ton
of stuff I listen to the music
catching a flick good food drinks drinks
with friends you know just enjoying join
life cool
cool
[Music]
do you have a condom I don't honestly I
don't have one on me I I wasn't
expecting to you know that's okay we
could just cuddle I really like hanging
out with you I really like hanging out
with you too and I've I love cuddling
I'm not just saying that she'll go buy
condoms yeah